and we're live we're going to watch
today from slapped ham
scariest things caught on live tv
and enjoying slapped ham's videos let's
see what happened
how you doing i'm calling and this is
slapped ham from a mysterious orb of
light called online
snapchat creepy doll rocking a chair on
a morning tv show
today we're looking at the scariest
things caught on live tv
but before we do consider hitting that
subscribe button for more awesome creepy
content
just like this okay
on the 27th of february 2018 a fox 6
tower camera captured something truly
bizarre over the skies of downtown
milwaukee
at 4 43 am the wake up news team noticed
that the camera was showing a couple of
strange lights
zigzagging through the night sky
dumbfounded by what she's witnessing one
of the hosts
asking her colleagues those fireworks
what is that aliens
after the footage was posted online it
was shared by meteorologists all over
the u.s
it also captured the attention of many
paranormal enthusiasts
who shared the footage on social media
where several people attempted to
explain the strange lies
some initially suggested asteroids while
others thought that the clip
actually showed evidence of alien
spacecraft that's what i think
one theory put forward by fox 6 news was
that the lights might have been seagulls
as moments earlier a reporter had
captured a video of a large flock flying
over the milwaukee county courthouse
many didn't buy this explanation however
noting the unusual movement patterns and
strange light trails of the shapes
while many theories have attempted to
explain the bizarre lights
to this day no one has been able to give
a definitive answer as to what they
actually
are what the [ __ ]
that's really bizarre this clip is an
excerpt taken from the 1978 episode
no no no no no no
who after several rounds of questions
finally chose rodney alcala
as the man she would take on a date
however despite the initial on camera
smiles bradshaw later decided not to go
out with alcohol
saying that she found him to be creepy a
decision that very well may have saved
her life
alcalar was accepted to appear on the
dating game despite
already being a convicted rapist
[Music]
after an extensive investigation jesus
charged with seven counts of murder
committed between 1971
and 1979. creepier still one homicide
investigator familiar with the case
speculated that the majority of his
murders might have gone
unsolved he estimated that alcala may
have killed as many as
50 women while others have suggested
that his murder count may even be as
high as 130.
this guy was on a dating show
that is nuts in 2009 wow
known as yahweh demonstrated to the abc
news team that he could summon
mysterious flying orbs on command
a resident of las vegas yahweh has been
able to summon ufos for more than 25
years
an ability he said he learned by reading
a hebrew version of the bible's old
testament
as the section begins the reporter is
understandably skeptical
then yahweh enters some kind of prayer
or trance state
suddenly an orb appears in the sky
as the bright orange oil is seen moving
through the air yahweh announces
it's going to nellis air force base it
wants to be seen
however a few moments later the strange
light turns around and begins to head
back towards the news crew
many have hailed this footage as proof
of the paranormal citing the fact that
the news crew picked the day
time and location of the interview
making it virtually impossible for
yahweh to have somehow faked the
incident oh damn
that's cool the reporter himself was at
a loss to explain what he had witnessed
saying that he was not quite sure what
those things were
and that if he hadn't seen them for
himself he probably would have just
laughed the whole thing off this whole
thing off
what do you think these mysterious orbs
could be fascinating
extraterrestrials or are they something
else jesus
let us know your thoughts in the
comments section below
well the government recently confirmed
there's ufos and aliens
this is a clip taken from a chilean
television program that documents
weddings and preparations leading up to
the day
as the camera films one family
organizing their event
they inadvertently catch something very
strange in the background
a bouquet of flowers is lifted out of
its bars and thrown across the room
what the hell wow some viewers thought
that the footage was genuine proof of
the
however skeptics were quick to suggest
that the flowers could have been
manipulated
using fishing line or a piece of string
the clip certainly does make you do a
double tape the sudden movement of the
flowers is startling and indefinite
contrast
to the theme of the video what would it
tell wow
weddings have to gain by faking such an
event
has the camera operator actually
captured evidence of a ghost
or is there something else at play here
i mean it's moving back
and and like landing isn't it that's
crazy there's very little
something up a bit about this clip other
than it was taken from a live broadcast
by a russian news crew
the reporter begins her story normally
when someone off camera suddenly says
something that causes her to quickly
turn around and look behind
as she turns the glowing awe begins to
move in from the left side
the strange shape appears to be just
meters from the reporter
who looks on in total amazement
for a few seconds before ascending into
the sky
as it's unclear where the footage was
taken it's difficult to give the video
any context
however the crew all sound genuinely
shocked at what they're witnessing
is it possible his team actually
captured proof of an alien spacecraft
or is there another explanation for this
strange phenomenon
anyone can understand what the reporter
and crew was saying would love to know
in the comments section below
on the 27th of december 2018 a massive
blue flash lit up the sky over queens
new york
the blast could be seen right across the
city as the manhattan sky oh [ __ ] these
river bridges
were silhouetted against the eerie blue
line it's like a godzilla
scared to twitter looking for an
explanation
while others posted their videos of the
blast
one local tweeted the electricity went
out then the explosion
my building coming and shaking sky was
lit up blue green wow
i did not hear about this i thought it
was the end
after the blast laguardia airport was
briefly engulfed by a total blackout
that's a real photo
temporarily flights had to be rerouted
to another airport
within minutes of the explosion the
internet was rife with theories about
what was causing the intense blue light
everything from alien spacecraft to the
supernatural was suggested
however the actual cause of the life
turned out to be far less fantastic
it was a transformer explosion at a con
editor
there's an actual answer
to investigate as the fire department
confirmed that the fire was under
control
luckily there were no reports of damage
to nearby houses and residents were
advised to avoid the area
before we get to that number one spot
and take a look at a creepy doll
moving on live tv remember to hit that
subscribe button and turn on channel
notifications
that way you'll be completely updated on
all our latest videos
real deliberate click
in 2017 debbie merrick from king's lynn
in norfolk uk
purchased three dolls from a second-hand
store
soon after taking them home she began to
notice that strange things seemed to
occur in the presence of one doll in
particular
one night her husband awoke to find
scratches all down his legs
to match the hand size and shape of the
doll
concerned merrick decided to put it in a
box and lock it in the garden shed
a few days later merrick returned to
check on the doll and was shocked to
discover that it seemed to have removed
a small pearl necklace from around its
own neck
oh creepy in this footage taken from an
interview on itv's this morning program
the merricks describe the eerie events
as the hosts question the couple the
rocking chair in which the doll is
sitting
suddenly
shaken they continue the interview the
merits then revealed that while staying
in a hotel the night before
debbie had awoken at 2 a.m to hear a
creepy swishing sound moving along the
side of her bed get rid of the doll
frightened by the whole experience the
merits eventually decided to sell the
creepy doll on ebay
where it was purchased by paranormal
investigator lee steer
from rotterham in south yorkshire uk
the day the doll arrived steer live
streamed its unboxing where more than 35
000 people tuned in to witness the event
no way some viewers even claimed that
they could see the doll's eyes moving on
camera
oh [ __ ] since then they've witnessed
flickering lines and heard
strange noises in their house lee's
father paul has even found scratches on
his arms similar to those experienced by
debbie
no way
if you want more scary videos just like
this then check out that one on the top
there
otherwise there's a creepy playlist
there for you to binge on
in the comments section below let us
know which one of these clips you
thought was the weirdest
and that's it for me i'll see you all
next time
definitely the blue light in new york
that's pretty
yeah anything that gets that big and
like a whole city can see it that's
pretty
i was being sarcastic because we know
the answer no
yeah oh it was a question
interesting stuff maybe not the scariest
one we've seen of slapped ham
that being said there's still some
really unsettling things i feel like the
comments are probably gonna be all about
the ufo ones
especially because of the fact that most
of this video is dedicated to there's
something [ __ ] weird in the sky
what is that we've been seeing like
footage like that for years right
but but to catch it on live tv is
different as opposed to like someone
sent this
in we're reporting on this but when
you're like filming something live and
then whoa what is this
like as you're recording yeah that is
creepy and a little bit harder to
debunk yeah and i have that in multiple
contexts too where it's like this one's
an interview with a guy that we set up
about this very phenomenon that we
managed to catch and then you have
another one that's just like oh we're
doing something else
and now there's random huge light in the
background and yeah like i think the
live tv elements
it's interesting it's a double-edged
sword because for those ones i feel like
it really helps
for something like the doll i'm not so
sure i mean the doll one
it's in a rocking chair
yeah in a studio like i feel like that
could easily have been orchestrated in
order like the story and
the scratch the story the scratches was
what got me most about that one but
but even the scratches with the dad of
the paranormal investigator who bought
it could have easily faked that yeah
this doll thing sounds like it was a
huge event to be on live tv and then
this guy
doing a live stream and gets 35 000
viewers on a live stream of unboxing it
i imagine that
like this this was an event i totally
did not hear about right there's just
too many things to
be like come on guys you're doing a
story about this on live tv you're gonna
want something like that to happen
that's an easy ass thing to fake in some
way
you gotta work to fake it but you can
still fake it you know
it's it's not difficult that being said
if it is real then
sorry for that paragraph would you like
google him he died he was talking alive
and murdered him when i'm sorry
i mean i believe i do believe in spooks
to me the creepiest one is this
is the one that probably most people
aren't talking about the ufo ones uh
like we're familiar with those i
i i believe aliens exist there was
something that came out recently like
was it the cia that said it happened
during the time of the protest or
you know yeah like like the cia releases
documents about that ufos are real
you know i've i i come on yeah let's get
on this train
they're real everyone get on this train
let's let's all get on the same train
i'm all for you know accepting others
beliefs but come on they're real
get on that tom de long train right
there but to piggyback off of what i
think you were going to say i yeah i
would have put the
the serial killer contestant as number
one because that's easily the freakiest
of all these
yeah anything like that honestly like i
love a good paranormal video i love a
good ufo video
the more hard to tell where doctoring
could have happened the better but when
it comes to these things nothing chills
me more
than something like that because it's
literally the person hiding in plain
sight who managed after
plenty of red flags to get onto this tv
show
i'm going to happen now i think nowadays
they would be like have you seen this
guy's record back then i guess they just
didn't care about that or didn't check
because that's
part of the old that's a pretty old uh
show the fact that
he was there all confident he got
selected it just shows you the power of
a sociopath and what the
manipulation tactics one can pull off on
live tv
on television yeah not only to get
picked as a panelist but he won
like he got a date this isn't some like
you know mysterious one-on-one encounter
that he had like this is on live tv he's
full in the crowd
it's full of everyone it's looking like
a romantic time good thing she didn't go
on the date with him because
that's like part of the scary scarier
element to me as well because he was
already convicted
before goes on here and then he commits
more crimes afterwards but this woman i
mean imagine that story that would have
been like
incredibly famous for years to come
dating contestant
ends up picking someone and gets
freaking murdered by him like that
that's unheard of
think about the what-if scenario of what
could have occurred there
that's the terrifying part yeah that's
the stuff that eats my mind the most
about these kinds of things is like
seeing a scary image is one thing but to
know that yeah
the thinnest barrier of if she just had
made a different decision
go out on a date with this guy things
would have been entirely different
there's something so tangible about
that to me that is very terrifying
coming back to the ufo one we're
we have the footage paused on the uh on
the one with the guy who summons
aliens oh yeah the orbs they said he's
on a air force base right
he said it was headed toward like when
it shot away from them it was headed
towards an air force base but he's not
he's not far from it though it can't be
especially if he's able to be like it's
headed towards the air force base like
the air force base can't be that far no
still know what it is
yeah yeah how did he contract it or
does he have some kind of uh connection
at the air force who's helping him out
yeah or something i don't know i mean it
sounds like i'm i'm fascinated by i'd be
curious to hear more just because of the
whole like i read a hebrew copy of the
old testament i read the torah and then
all of a sudden i could contour what's
in the torah
that would do that i'm not that's a
great question somebody go and
read it and see if you can conjure your
own orbs is there something in the old
testament i missed the old testament is
actually full of like party tricks
magic you know ways to dazzle your
friends with you know ufos
this is a spell book yes bring a demon
and then make testaments all about
christ you can make this doll come to
life you can resurrect spirits it'll get
you on any dating show
really this copy of the old testament is
really really
cool good for him or maybe he just got
super lucky that day
i guess that one was funny to me because
of all the ones i've seen
it was somehow the least suspect in the
terms of at least the presentation was
like this guy said he could do it he did
it the news station
picked all the circumstances and we
still don't know so in a way sure they
picked him because the planet
yeah that's that's the one part i was
like well if they even give you like a
date in advance you could probably
you know yeah this is especially if he
has his hands on something like this
where he can
manipulate whatever i i don't know where
he can yeah summon the whole because i'm
like wait a minute
wait a minute what if if he keeps
summoning ufos do they show up
what are they talking about are they
like why do we keep going back to this
guy well that's the thing is they're
unidentified we don't know what he's
conjuring and that's the problem i don't
know if this is some kind of
visual like optical illusion or if it's
a substance
or because ufo doesn't necessarily just
mean ship it's got to be flying and an
object
and of mystery they just keep circling
back over him
yeah every time he calls it's like when
you get a phone call
and you're like oh crap this might be
important damn it's that same hotel
calling me yeah this guy's awesome you
wanna marry a hotel gym then
so it's not what's happening here just
someone going
like oh crap it's him again he keeps
calling us he's honest
turn around spiritual spam why do we
keep
answering his call maybe yeah maybe
he found in the old testament a way to
summon a spirit back for a hot minute
and they can only get so far down to the
ground and then they got to go right
back up to heaven
which is apparently just above that air
base i mean the fox news one that looks
like it could be a wide variety of
things from alien stuff to some type of
weird
array of meteor showers to me the one
that was creepiest was the
foreign language one not foreign to
whoever is native language that is but
to us
foreign it was russian but in that
russian video
her reaction the camera's like whoa whoa
that's not what we're hearing yeah that
that actually seems like the most
unsettling to me because they look
really thrown off guard
yeah and the footage is so grimy too
like it really looks like it
came from in a little time in place like
a word of the world
thing where it's like descending from
the ground up yeah yeah yeah that just
like leaves in the distance yeah
and it's just like a mysterious light
too that's the other thing is it doesn't
even seem to have like a tangibility i
know what happened
this guy summoned a ufo and then that
ufo came out from under the ground
they're at the i gotta make it to carls
they're at the air force base just over
there
that's where the light went and then it
went right back over to the other guy
where he conjured it from and there you
go if you cut those two clips together
they work perfectly
this is just count as one thing all
right guys
well which one of these do you think is
real which one do you think creeped you
out
the most the most we gotta check out
another ghost video next week
guys subscribe to slap ham if you
haven't done so already
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell to get
notified whenever we've got a youtube
video up hit that like button blah blah
blah
gene manuel or panaman pitchers
jean is a fairly new patronage but
right now i'm finding out so much
information about him he's killing the
game in terms of his career pursuits
had an internship for a really popular
netflix show he actually lives in our
part of california
not too far away from us so the odds of
us bumping into one another and him
touching me and giving me kobet are very
likely to happen and i welcome it with
you gene
sneeze on us sneeze on us all you want
you should go check out his site panama
pictures
on uh apple books and vimeo as well he
even did a batman beyond short film this
guy
is wildly creative very passionate very
driven
but more importantly he's a hell of a
patronage
so thanks gene for being you and you
keep that brown
color alive since you specified in our
messages about
how you and i are both brown oh hey and
how john is a
white woke god oh that's that's all
that's a lot to live up to i hope i can
do you proud because i'll just stop the
racism
john i ended up punching it in the face
i love racism
but i'm trying to stop it's not about
your racism
it's talking about other people's races
oh i can stop everybody else's races
that's what i was trying to do
it's okay in the name of panama pictures
punch sorry gene
you